So let us look at the semantic network representation of the relationship
between A and B. In one view of the transformation from A to B,
we can think of q, the outer circle, as remaining unchanged, and
p the inner circle, as getting deleted. Let's look at
another view of the transformation from A to B. In this view, we can think of
p as getting expanded and q, the outer circle, as getting deleted.
Both of these views are valid views. If both of these views are valid,
then how would anyone decide? How would an AI agent decide which view to select?
Let us suppose that the AI agent had a metric by which it could
decide upon the ease of transformation from A to B.
Let us suppose that, that metric assigned different weights to different kind of
transformations. You will notice that these transformations like scaling,
rotation, reflection make for a fine transformations. In this scale,
a larger value like 5 points, means more ease of transformation and
greater similarity. A lower value means less ease of transformation and
more difficult transformation and less similarity. Given the scale,
let us calculate the weight of transformations for
both transformation #1, and transformation #2. In transformation #1,
you can see that p is getting deleted, which we gave a weight of 1. And
q remains unchanged, which we gave a weight of 5. So the total weight here is 6.
In case of transformation #2, the weight of p being expanded, we said will be 2,
scaled. And, q getting deleted is 1, so the total weight is 3.
If you prefer the first transformation over the second transformation,
then we can see why someone will answer the square is the correct answer, and
not the triangle. Let us return to this exercise. And now we can see why
both 3 and 5 are legitimate answers. We can also see why an AI agent
may prefer 5, given the similarity metric that we talked about in the last shot.